Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Forschergeist, dem Podcast des Stifterverbandes für die deutsche Wissenschaft.
Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße alle hier zu einer weiteren Ausgabe, in der wir uns heute ein wenig der Stadt zuwenden wollen.
Grob gesagt geht es ein wenig um stadtplanerische Aspekte, aber sicherlich nicht um klassische Stadtplanung, sondern wir wollen uns einen Begriff näher anschauen, den man kennt unter Resilienz.
Die Widerstandsfähigkeit der Stadt oder wem auch immer.
Um das zu klären, begrüße ich zunächst einmal meinen Gesprächspartner, nämlich Jochen Rabe, schönen guten Tag.
Schönen guten Tag.
Jochen, du bist Professor für urbane Resilienz und Digitalisierung.
Korrekt. Wie der Engländer sagen würde, a mouthful
Und das Ganze hier in Berlin am Einstein-Zentrum.
Wie heißt das nochmal vollständig?
Einstein-Zentrum digitale Zukunft.
Einstein-Zentrum digitale … gibt es noch andere Einstein-Zentren, die sich nicht mit der digitalen Zukunft?
Ja in der Tat.
Das Land Berlin hat vor – ich weiß gar nicht genau – aber noch gar nicht so langer Zeit mal unter der Einstein- Stiftung angefangen, Forschungsschwerpunkte im Rahmen von Einstein-Zentren zu machen.
Und dieses Einstein-Zentrum digitale Zukunft gibt es jetzt seit fast einem Jahr, einem guten Jahr.
Also alles noch ganz frisch, ganz heiße Kartoffel?
Ganz heiße Kartoffel und in zweierlei Hinsicht glaube ich ein kühnes Vorhaben.
Zum einen, weil man sich der digitalen Zukunft stellt und endlich mal sehr interdisziplinär.
Also das Ziel ist, am Ende bis zu 50 Professuren zu haben aus verschiedensten Blickwinkeln.
Ebenso kühn ist aber und das verstehe ich umso besser, weil ich mich in den letzten 20-30 Jahren meiner Berufslaufbahn sehr viel mit Interdisziplinarität beschäftigt habe, kühn ist, dass alle Universitäten der Stadt zusammenkommen und unter einem Dach und interdisziplinär forschen wollen.
Also alle as in HU, TU, FU Berlin?
Charité ist noch dabei, die Fachhochschulen sind auch jeweils mit einer Professur oder zwei Professuren dabei.
Und das natürlich mit ganz individuellen Forschungsschwerpunkten, aber Ziel ist es, dass diese zukünftigen 50 Professuren alle auch miteinander arbeiten.
Wir haben ein sehr schönes Gebäude zur Verfügung gestellt bekommen, nämlich sehr zentral das Robert-Koch-Forum.
Ursprünglich war gedacht, dass wir da auch alle unter einem Dach zusammenkommen, das ging dann leider aus Platzgründen nicht, bzw. ein Teil des Gebäudes muss noch weiter saniert werden und das dauert nunmal.
Aber wir haben da jetzt eine Plattform, die dann die sehr vielseitigen Aktivitäten des Einstein-Zentrum digitale Zukunft eine Plattform geben und vom Hackathon bis zu Workshops bis zu Tagesveranstaltungen dort alles passieren kann.
Bevor wir vielleicht da noch ein bisschen mehr mal drauf eingehen, was mit dieser Professur und vielleicht auch mit dem Umfeld im Einstein-Zentrum so noch verbunden ist, würde mich natürlich erst mal so ein bisschen dein Werdegang interessieren.
Wie du denn jetzt in diese Rolle überhaupt hineingeraten bist, weil du bist ja jetzt nicht so der klassische Wissenschaftler-, Akademiker-Laufbahn-Typ.
Das ist völlig richtig.
Also wenn man zurückzuckt denkt man manchmal, ich habe das sehr genau geplant, das Thema Stadt einzukreisen von allen verschiedenen oder von vielen verschiedenen Blickwinkeln, die dafür notwendige sind.
Angefangen vom Geld, ich habe irgendwann mal für die Deutsche Bank gearbeitet.
Habe dann mein Hobby, die Landschaftsarchitektur, zu meinem Beruf gemacht.
Habe dann gesagt, das dazwischen alleine kann es auch nicht sein, ich muss mich mit Architektur und Städtebau und Stadtplanung beschäftigt.
Das habe ich dann studiert in Hamburg an der Kunsthochschule damals noch und in Ox…
Was genau studiert, also Stadtplanung?
Stadtplanung und Architektur.
Ja.
Das war an der HfbK, damals noch Hochschule für bildende Künste in Hamburg.
Und einen Teil davon durfte ich in Oxford schon verbringen, wo ich ein Forschungsprojekt gemacht habe, wo ich mich mit dem Innen und Außen in der gebauten Umwelt und wie das zusammenkommt beschäftigen durfte.
Und dann ging es weiter, parallel habe ich schon selbständig gearbeitet.
Ich hatte immer das Bedürfnis, die Praxis mit der Theorie zu verknüpfen.
Habe dann, war schon fast drauf und dran, in Edinburgh ein PHD zu machen, kam dann aber an einen anderen Masterstudiengang in Cambridge, der sich mit der Interdisziplinarität in der Bauwelt eigentlich beschäftigte.
Die ich viel relevanter fand in dem Zusammenhang, weil die Engländer relativ früh schon begriffen haben, dass komplexe große Bauvorhaben auch sehr, also ebenso komplexe interdisziplinäre Strukturen brauchen.
Und somit durfte ich da dann noch zwei Jahre studieren.
Bin dann aber in die Privatwirtschaft gegangen und war da die letzten, also bis vorletztes Jahr.
Und habe dort unter anderem für zwei große multinationale Beratungs- und Ingenieurfirmen, Arup und BuroHappold gearbeitet, die gerade dafür bekannt sind, glaube ich, weltweit Qualität zu liefern mit eben dem Anspruch möglichst viele Disziplinen zusammenzubringen, um komplexe Lösungen drumherum …
Wie heißen die beiden nochmal?
Das eine ist Arup, Arup auf englisch, Over Arup ist dafür berühmt geworden, dadurch dass er der einzige Ingenieur war, der die Sydney Opera eigentlich wirklich bauen konnte.
Entworfen ist sie von jemand anders, aber die Ingenieursfähigkeiten wurden von Arup beigesteuert.
Und BuroHappold wurde von Ted Happold gegründet, die zusammen schon Arup aufgebaut hatten.
Und beide haben sich dann entwickelt zunehmend zu Firmen, die auch im städtischen Maßstab unterwegs sind und große Projekte weltweit haben, die von Masterplänen bis zu Stadtentwicklung gehen.
Das heißt, du hast tatsächlich quasi das Thema Stadt und wie sie sich entwickelt so aus den unterschiedlichsten Blickwinkeln von selber Baum pflanzen bis hin zu Kredit geben sozusagen alles mal eingesehen?
Also ich weiß nicht, war die Bankaktivität auch in diesem Kontext oder war das mal was ganz anderes?
Das war ganz am Anfang meiner Karriere, wo ich glaube ich auch noch nicht vielleicht so richtig wusste, wo es hingehen sollte.
Das hat bis heute durchaus Bedeutung, denn wenn man sich die Stadtentwicklung anschaut, dann hat das natürlich sehr sehr viel mit auch Geld und der Wirtschaft zu tun.
Und ich glaube, wenn man die Prinzipien, die da im Gange sind, nicht versteht, dann kann man auch schwierig Entwicklung lostreten, die vielleicht nachhaltiger oder resilienter sind.
Und wie kam es denn dann zu diesem Wechsel in das akademische Glied?
Wir haben schon in den letzten Jahren ein großes Forschungsprojekt gemacht im Rahmen meiner privatwirtschaftlichen Tätigkeit bei BuroHappold.
Das drehte sich um Elektromobilität und im Grunde genommen, wie man dieses System Elektromobilität im städtischen Kontext landen lassen kann.
Also ein System zu entwickeln ist relativ „einfach“, aber das wirklich dann in der Stadt und im gebauten Kontext überall unterzubringen ist hochgradig komplex.
Und wie ich schon vorher meinte, ich bin eigentlich immer dran interessiert gewesen, was tut sich in der Wissenschaft?
Ich habe versucht, diese Forschungsprojekte, wissenschaftliche Tätigkeiten in meine privatwirtschaftlichen Aktivitäten einzubinden.
Und irgendwann wurde dann an mich herangetreten, dass dieses Einstein-Zentrum digitale Zukunft gegründet werden sollte und dass nach jemandem gesucht wurde, der sich mit dem Thema Stadt auskennt.
Ganz konkrete Anlass war, muss ich vielleicht noch kurz erklären, dass jede Professur am Einstein-Zentrum digitale Zukunft ein Stifterkonstrukt ist.
Also es gibt Stifter, die eine Professur fördern und jeweils zu jedem Euro wird noch 50% von der Stadt dazugetan.
In meinem Falle sind das zwei der landeseigenen Wohnungsbaugesellschaften.
Das ist die Howoge und die Gesobau, die glaube ich sehr früh erkannt haben, welches Potenzial dieses Einstein-Zentrum haben kann und gleichzeitig zu dem Zeitpunkt hatten sie eins der größten Wohnungsbauvorhaben in Berlin, was sie gemeinsam angehen wollten.
Was dann leider Opfer geworden ist, was heißt Opfer, es ist aber erst mal zurückgestellt worden in den Koalitionsverhandlungen in den letzten.
Aber mit beiden arbeite ich jetzt auch zusammen an meinen Forschungsprojekten.
Und beide sind sehr spannend, weil die landeseigenen Wohnungsbaugesellschaften in Berlin natürlich große Wohnungsbestände haben und betreiben und sich glaube ich auch zunehmend in der Verantwortung sehen, nicht nur Vermieter zu sein, sondern auch über den städtischen Kontext nachzudenken.
Das heißt, in dem Einstein-Zentrum wird im Prinzip so mehrere Strömungen an Kompetenz zusammengefasst, die sich im weiteren Sinne mit Stadtplanung beschäftigen oder ist das auch nur ein Aspekt?
Ich meine digitale Zukunft ist natürlich jetzt ein sehr weitreichender Begriff, wie weit streut das dann noch aus?
Also dreht sich alles mehr um dieses urbane Thema auf die ein oder andere Art und Weise oder gibt es auch nochmal Bereiche, die in eine ganz andere Richtung weisen?
Nein gar nicht, also Stadt ist einer von ganz ganz vielen Aspekten.
Also es ist wirklich offen.
Es gab einen Antrag, der Profile für Professuren umrissen hatte, das waren diese 50 Profile.
Und da ist Stadt nur eins von vielen Themen.
Stadt ist insofern interessant, weil es immer ein Querschnittsthema ist, es gibt aber auch hochspezialisierte Themen.
Es gibt ganz klassische technologische Fragestellungen, die behandelt werden von 5G-Technologie, wie sehen die Netzwerke der Zukunft aus?
Aber es gibt auch die Mediziner, die sich mit BigData beschäftigen, was passiert eigentlich, wenn man zum Beispiel in der Radiologie Zugang hat zu massenhaften Kernspinbildern?
Kann man dann neue Diagnoseverfahren entwickeln etc.?
Ich glaube an der Charité die sind noch dabei.
Momentan muss man sagen sind wir zu acht glaube ich.
Denn so was, wie du schon sagtest, braucht auch eine Zeit, so was aufs Gleis zu legen.
Und dann Berufungsverfahren haben auch alle ihre eigenen Gesetzmäßigkeiten und Zeitläufe, insofern muss das noch kommen.
Aber die digitale Zukunft ist hier tatsächlich ganz ganz breit angelegt.
Ich habe als einer der ersten Dinge, die ich gemacht habe, ist, mir diese Profile mal anzugucken und zu sagen, was kann für Stadt relevant sein.
Und da kamen ganz viele Themen auf.
Es gibt auch SmartWater, SmartMobility, mehrere Bereiche, die für Stadt sehr sehr relevant sein werden.
Und dann ist das Ansinnen eben, dass diese Professuren sich auch zusammentun.
Das ist auch strukturell durchaus eingebaut, also an seine Ausstattung kommt man eigentlich nur dann, wenn man auch interdisziplinäre Forschungsprojekte aufstellt.
Und was ich sehr begrüße.
Aber wie du schon richtig meintest, das beginnt eigentlich gerade erst und beginnt jetzt aber auch, Früchte zu tragen.
Nun kommen wir mal auf diesen Begriff der urbanen Resilienz.
Also wenn man jetzt mal Resilienz nachschlägt, dann ist das ja so ein bisschen so die Fähigkeit, sich anderen Prozessen auch anzupassen oder nach Störungen diese in den Griff zu bekommen.
Mal so ganz frei daher assoziiert.
Wie würdest du den Begriff urbane Resilienz in dem Zusammenhang sehen, wie leitest du dir das her, wo kommt der Begriff her?
Ist das überhaupt schon ein etablierter Begriff oder ist das jetzt etwas, was ihr euch da aus der Nase gezogen habt?
Also ich würde mal sagen, in Deutschland hat es bisher eine Ausprägung, die der internationalen Interpretation noch ein bisschen hinterher hängt.
Also Resilienz wird in der Tat oftmals übersetzt als Widerstandskraft.
Oder was passiert nach Schockerlebnissen, also zum Beispiel einer Flut?
Wie kann die Stadt darauf reagieren oder welche Systeme gibt es, um den Status quo von vorher wieder herzustellen?
Katastrophenschutz nennt man das Ganze.
Das ist tatsächlich ein Teil der Übung, das ist aber weniger der Teil, für den ich mich interessiere.
Es geht eigentlich um Wiedererneuerungskräfte im Angesicht von längerfristigen Krisen.
Also Dingen, die Stadtentwicklung beeinflussen, und zwar nicht nur in einem einzigen Moment, in Form einer Katastrophe, sondern eigentlich eine Herausforderung sind, auf die reagiert werden muss.
In Form von wie auch immer den richtigen Policies oder tatsächlich auch mit physischen Maßnahmen.
Also im Kern für mich liegt eigentlich die evolutionäre Resilienz, wie können sich Städte weiterentwickeln.
Ich bringe manchmal, das ist in der Tat so ein bisschen ein sperriger Begriff, manchmal wird auch gesagt, das ist die neue Nachhaltigkeit, die neue Sustainability.
Nein ist es nicht, es ersetzt sie auch nicht, es ist einfach eine Reaktion darauf, dass verstanden wird, dass wir mit herkömmlicher Planung über Jahrzehnte teilweise nicht mehr dem Wandel entsprechen können, den wir gleichzeitig erleben.
Und in Vorlesungen bringe ich manchmal eine große Kupferspirale mit, so wie sie in alten Sofas drinstecken und stelle sie auf den Tisch und lass die Leute draufdrücken.
Und das, was zurückkommt, ist im Grunde genommen Resilienz.
Das kann man manchmal physisch ganz gut begreifen.
Es ist insofern leicht missverständlich, weil es eben nicht so richtig abbildet, dass nach einem Ereignis oder nach einer Krise, wo dann wie auch immer darauf reagiert wird, dass das Quartier, meinetwegen das Stadtquartier hinterher nicht mehr genau das gleiche ist wie vorher.
Also das entscheidende bei der Resilienzforschung ist auch, dass man sich Wandlung anguckt, aber nicht unkritisch einfach sagt, naja dann ist es hinterher einfach was anderes.
Sondern dass man auch versucht, das Wesen von einem Stadtquartier vorher zu erfassen und natürlich auch zu erhalten in der Wandlung dieser Quartiere.
Ist der Begriff evolutionäre Resilienz nicht so ein bisschen so ein Doppelmoppel?
Weil steckt nicht genau dieses Resiliente in Evolution mit drin?
Dass man sich immer wieder an die Meteoriteneinschläge sozusagen anpasst und versucht, so möglichst das was man eigentlich betreiben möchte, wiederherzustellen, aber dann eben unter Umständen unter leicht geänderten Bedingungen, was ja dann eigentlich die Evolution auch immer wieder mit antreibt?
Wenn man auf natürliche Prozesse guckt, unbedingt, da ist das mit drin.
Da gibt es Zyklen, die darauf eigentlich sogar basieren, dass Schocks eintreten.
Also es gibt Bäume, die keimen nur dann, wenn ein Waldbrand über sie einher gestürzt ist, weil nur dann die Saat aufspringt.
In der Stadtplanung ist das aber natürlich schwierig, mit entsprechendem Versagen zu planen.
Natürlich versagt Stadtplanung oder versagen Städte hier und da auch, nicht immer gleich in Form eines Brandes.
Wobei auch das gab es.
Also ich will mal sagen, die Brandschutzregulierung, die wir haben, die Brandschutzgesetze, die sehr weitgehend sind, kann man alle darauf zurückführen, dass fast jede Stadt in Europa irgendwann mal einen großen Brand hatte.
Aber wenn man nach vorne guckt und Planungen aufstellt, ist es natürlich schwer kommunizierbar, dass man auch wirklich ein Systemversagen mit einplanen oder mit einrechnen muss.
Also an der Stelle ist es halt Anlass zu einem Masterplan.
Masterplan sagt, okay so wird es in 20 Jahren und das bauen wir jetzt.
Das ist in einem Neubaukontext vielleicht möglich, auch da würde ich das bezweifeln, dass man über so lange Zeit – und das ist beim Maßstab Stadt immer eine ganz wichtige Unterscheidung machen müssen.
Stadt entwickelt sich über viel längere Zeiträume als ein Gebäude zum Beispiel.
Ein Gebäude hat eine Planungszeit von 2-3 Jahren oder so, manchmal sogar schneller, manchmal länger.
Und dann baut man das auch nochmal über 1-3 Jahre und dann steht das Ding da.
Und eine Stadt hat natürlich viel viel mehr Leute, die es betrifft, viel mehr Leute, die mitplanen müssen.
Viel mehr auch immer wieder Abschnitte, wo neues entschieden werden muss.
Es ist kein einzelnes isolierbares Geschehenvorhaben, sondern es ist ein System, was geplant werden muss, bzw. wo wir jetzt auch gerade mit der Digitalisierung neue Instrumente bekommen, um besser zu verstehen eigentlich überhaupt, wie Stadt sich entwickelt in einer Vielzahl von Systemen.
Im Grunde genommen ist es ein System von Systemen.
Ja die Langfristigkeit und die Breite der Themen, die man quasi auf urbaner Ebene berücksichtigen muss, macht hier vor allem das Salz in der Suppe.
Ja wie ich schon sagte, also Stadt ist ein Querschnittsthema, da muss man auch immer aufpassen, wie man Komplexitäten so reduziert, dass man auch noch aussagekräftig Dinge erforschen kann und auch darstellen kann.
Aber auch gerade deswegen war das Einstein-Zentrum digitale Zukunft für mich so spannend, denn im privatwirtschaftlichen Kontext Innovation zu betreiben ist nicht ganz einfach, selbst wenn es ganz weit oben auf der Agenda von vielen Unternehmen ist heutzutage.
Da wird natürlich dann aber trotzdem auch dafür gesorgt werden müssen, dass man da profitabel unterwegs ist.
Und ich glaube, den Innovationsschub, den wir leisten müssen oder dem wir jetzt begegnen, den mal so nebenher mitzumachen, ist eine Herausforderung, die in der Privatwirtschaft schwerlich abgebildet werden kann.
Ich will das nicht ausschließen, aber es ist viel, was man da stemmen muss.
Das gleiche trifft aber auch auf Universitäten zu, wenn man weiter in Silos unterwegs ist.
Und auch da an der Stelle gratuliere ich der Stadt Berlin, die sich entschieden hat zu diesem, wie gesagt, kühnen Konstrukt, alle Universitäten mal unter einem Dach zusammenzubringen mit einer Fragestellung.
Und ganz explizit zu sagen, bitte kommt zusammen und geforscht zusammen interdisziplinäre Fragestellungen, die uns beschäftigen werden.
Wie geht man da nun ran im Rahmen einer solchen Professur?
Wie denkst du darüber, wie bricht man jetzt dieses Thema urbane Resilienz?
Oder ich sage mal auch, zukünftige Stadtentwicklung, insbesondere unter Berücksichtigung auch des Digitalisierungsaspektes?
Kann man ja glaube ich so festhalten, dass das hier auch ein starker Schwerpunkt ist.
Wie strukturiert man das?
Ich meine, diesen Studiengang gibt es ja in dem Sinne noch gar nicht oder?
Also ist das nicht ein mehr oder weniger neues Konzept auch?
Also es ist ja insofern kein expliziter Studiengang.
Also die Professur ist angelegt an der TU Berlin, da lehre ich auch.
Die Professur kommt mit einem vollen Lehrdeputat daher.
Die ist verteilt zwischen dem Institut für Architektur.
Es gibt noch einen Real Estate Master Studiengang, wo ich auch lehre.
Dann gibt es noch ein Institut für Stadt- und Regionalplanung, mit denen ich auch enge Verbindungen halte.
Und insofern gibt es keinen expliziten urbane Resilienz Master.
Okay, aber es ist quasi ein Kursanteil verschiedener anderer Studiengänge aus dem Architekturbereich?
Es ist die Lehre, genau.
Einstein-Zenter digitale Zukunft Professur ist eigentlich im Wesen eine Forschungsprofessur, würde ich sagen.
Aber gleichzeitig dürfen wir auch viel lehren.
Ich sage ganz bewusst und völlig unironisch dürfen, denn gerade in der Stadtplanung bzw. in der Architektur ist projektgebundenes Forschen eigentlich glücklicherweise schon seit geraumer Zeit Gang und Gäbe.
Also wir haben zwar noch Vorlesungen, aber wenn in anderen Studiengängen heutzutage die Lehre vornehmlich aus Vorlesungen besteht, sind es bei uns eigentlich meistens Projekte, anhand deren dann noch zusätzliche Aspekte geklärt werden.
Also wir haben ein Projekt momentan, was sich mit der Zukunft in Neuhohenschönhausen beschäftigt.
Da erlauben wir uns mal, irgendwie 20 Jahre nach vorne zu denken und sagen, welche Einflüsse finden wir da momentan, welche sind wahrscheinlich, welche wünschen wir uns?
Das ist auch ganz wichtig glaube ich bei Zukunftsfragen, dass wir zu wenig darüber nachdenken, wie wünschen wir uns eigentlich unsere Zukunft.
Nicht nur, wie begegnen wir den ganzen Herausforderungen, ergeben der Digitalisierung oder was auch immer das ist, sondern was wünschen wir uns für uns?
Und das passiert dann zum Beispiel in Form eines einsemestrigen sehr intensiven Entwurfstudios, was ich gemeinsam mit einem Kollegen gemacht habe.
Und jetzt bis hin zu einer öffentlichen Ausstellung führt, wo wir denn auch hoffentlich mit den Bürgern vor Ort einfach mal über die Zukunft reden.
Und die Zukunftsvisionen oder Szenarien muss man eigentlich eher sagen, mit denen debattieren, aber auch vielleicht Maßnahmen, die man jetzt ergreifen kann, um zu einer gewünschten Zukunft zu kommen.
Ich habe es jetzt ein bisschen durcheinander geworfen mit der Forschung und Lehre.
Finde ich jetzt aber eigentlich im Ergebnis ganz interessant.
Weil, ich meine, wenn man es gut anlegt, dann kann man ja auch aus dieser Lehre heraus eine ganze Menge Inspiration und Marschrichtung herausbilden.
Ich weiß nicht, wie viele Studenten sind da jetzt angedockt ungefähr so über die ganze …?
Also so ein Entwurfsstudio hat in der Regel so um die gut 20 Studenten.
Es kommt immer auf das Format drauf an, im nächsten Semester werden wir ein sogenanntes Lehr-Forschungs-Projekt machen, wo wir uns in etwas kleinerer Runde, aber noch konzentrierter, mit Fragestellungen beschäftigen.
Diesmal dann in einem Gebiet, das hier in Berlin ist, das Märkische Viertel, wo der andere Stifter meine Professur, die Gesobau, schon sehr gespannt darauf ist, was wir da eigentlich an Zukunftsmöglichkeiten auftun können.
Also das Märkische Viertel ist auch so einer dieser großen 70er Jahre …
Ja das ist insofern ganz spannend, Neuhohenschönhausen wie gesagt da ist die Howoge zuständig.
Das ist ja eine Großwohnsiedlung, die noch bis zu den letzten Jahren der DDR gebaut wurde, also eine östliche Großwohnsiedlung.
Das Märkische Viertel ist eine westliche und das ist die Gesobau, die in diesem Falle einen Großteil der Immobilien verwaltet und besitzt.
Und beide Organisationen, wie ich vorher schon meinte, sind sehr beschäftigt damit, sich zu fragen, wie müssen die sich aufstellen in der Zukunft?
Also die wie ich finde sehr zukunftsinteressierten Vorstände der beiden Gesellschaften standen vor unseren Studenten und haben gesagt, was müssen wir tun, damit ihr hier leben wollt in der Zukunft?
Also das begrüße ich ganz ausdrücklich und an der Stelle kann Lehre wirklich auch neue Perspektiven mitbringen, wo wir fast schon alten Säcke, sage ich mal so, vielleicht bestimmt auch interessantes beizutragen haben, aber wo diese Perspektive der jungen Forscher sicherlich mit dabei sein muss.
Kommen wir doch mal auf die Forschung.
Also wie strukturiert man das, wie bist du da rangegangen?
Ich meine es ist ja im Prinzip jetzt erst mal ein weitgehend unbestelltes Feld gewesen, da kann man sich dann ja im Prinzip auch nochmal komplett neu ausrichten.
Wie strukturierst du für dich so die Forschungsgebiete, in die man reinschaut?
Auf welche Art und Weise bearbeitest du dieses Thema der urbanen Resilienz für dich?
An der Stelle kann ich vielleicht nochmal kurz ausholen, denn ich meinte in Deutschland ist es noch nicht so ganz verbreitetet die Resilienz, so wie ich sie beschrieben habe, bzw. wie sie mich interessiert.
Im internationalen Kontext ist das ein bisschen anders.
Ich durfte auch noch in meiner letzten beruflichen Inkarnation als strategischer Berater der Rockefeller Foundation zuarbeiten.
Die Rockefeller Foundation hat vor, das muss jetzt schon 5-7 Jahre her sein, ein Programm aufgesetzt, was da heißt „100 resilient Citys“.
Ein sehr großes gefördertes Vorhaben, ich glaube jenseits von 100 Millionen, die da eingesetzt wurden von der Rockefeller Foundation, die das Ziel hatte, 100 Städte zu finden und für diese 100 Städte Resilienzstrategien aufzustellen.
Und diese Resilienzstrategien decken beides ab, sowohl Katastrophenschutz, denn in vielen dieser Städte ist der Katastrophenschutz noch nicht so gewährleistet, wie er bei uns in Deutschland gewährleistet ist, aber es ging ganz explizit halt auch immer um die Wandlungsfähigkeit von Städten.
Also mehr der Bereich, der mich interessiert.
Und an der Stelle ist das wie gesagt nich völliges Neuland, sondern international tut sich da schon eine ganze Menge.
Mich interessieren insbesondere die Faktoren, die quasi die Stadtplanung neu herausfordern.
Wo einfach Geschwindigkeiten auftreten und ins Spiel kommen, wie Städte bespielt werden, wie sie funktionieren, wie sie benutzt werden, auf die die Stadtplanung schneller und besser reagieren muss.
Sagen wir mal Verkehr zum Beispiel, der Verkehr wird immer noch mehr und mehr, wir brauchen andere multimodale Verkehrs- oder Mobilitätskonzepte, die natürlich nachhaltiger sind als die jetzigen.
Da wird sehr viel über autonomes Fahren nachgedacht heutzutage und wie das eingeführt wird.
Und wir fragen uns dann, welche Auswirkungen hat das auf Räumlichkeiten?
Wie Quartiere funktionieren?
Wir beide haben uns kennengelernt im Rahmen der Queen's Lecture hier an der TU gehalten.
Ich habe leider den Namen vergessen, aber von dem CTO von Uber, den ich hinterher dann fragen durfte, etwas provokant fragen durfte, ob wir die autonomen Fahrzeug eigentlich nicht gefährlich bauen müssen.
Und die Antwort war, nein nein wir müssen sie natürlich sicher bauen, was natürlich auch richtig ist und es heutzutage versucht wird, aber wenn man sich die autonomen Autos anguckt heutzutage, werden sie eigentlich so gedacht, dass sie eigentlich immer in jeder Situation anhalten können müssen.
Denn es ist einfach nicht akzeptabel, dass ein Vehikel, was keinen Verantwortlichen an Bord hat, einen Unfall verursacht.
Momentan funktioniert aber unser gesamtes Stadt- und Verkehrsgefüge darauf, dass die Leute Respekt bis Angst haben davor, einfach auf die Straße zu laufen, weil sie wissen, da könnte sie was überfahren.
Wenn wir aber autonomes Fahren einführen mit Vehikeln, die immer reagieren, dann drehen sich plötzlich die Hierarchien im öffentlichen Raum.
Und gerade hier in Berlin, wie wir wissen, haben wir hier sehr herausfordernde Fußgänger und Fahrradfahrer, völlig zurecht.
Wenn die spitz bekommen würden, dass sie zu jeder Zeit über die Straße laufen könnten, ohne dass was passiert, dann haben wir völlig andere Mobilitätssysteme.
Und so was muss einfach mitgedacht werde, und an der Stelle wird zu oft einfach nur über die Technologie nachgedacht und zu wenig über, wie Stadt funktioniert.
Welche Player in der Stadt eigentlich am wirksamsten sind.
Welche vielleicht auch am stärksten berücksichtigt werden müssen.
Zoubin Ghahramani So hieß er. Der Mensch ist auch ein wirklich schwer zu erinnernder Name.
Also die Antwort, ist tatsächlich eine ganz schwierige Frage, die Antwort, die dann kam, war glaube ich, man müsste dann entsprechend das Fehlverhalten regulieren.
Wo ich denke, das kann man machen in Maßen, also dann Tickets ausstellen, und Strafen erteilen.
Aber was ist da durchsetzbar?
Das sind dann 5-15 Euro vielleicht hier in Berlin und werden sich deswegen lauter Fahrradfahrer und Fußgänger daran halten und wie will man das überhaupt kontrollieren?
Ich glaube, an der Stelle ist noch nicht zu Ende gedacht worden.
Steigen wir doch da mal vielleicht ein bisschen konkreter auch ein.
Du hast es jetzt schon ein paar mal erwähnt, und wir sind schon halb drin in dem Thema, Verkehr.
Ich denke, das ist so ein kleiner Nobrainer mittlerweile, dass man sagt, Verkehr ist in der Stadt eine Herausforderung.
Ich meine, das war es in gewisser Hinsicht schon immer.
Oder man kann aber auch sagen, es war vor allem auch lange lagen Zeit, war der Verkehr auch so ein treibendes Element, was quasi so ein bisschen auch die sonstige Stadtplanung ein bisschen vor sich hergeschoben hat.
Da war diese ganze Begeisterung über die Optionen des persönlichen Transports, weniger des öffentlichen Transports.
Das Auto hat dann spätestens in den 60/70er Jahren einfach auch die Städte mehr  oder weniger vor sich hergeschoben.
Breite Straßen, Autobahnen, umgepflügte Stadtteile, und dann halt so weitergehende Illusionen, wie die Abschaffung des öffentlichen Nahverkehrs.
Das haben wir ja hier in Westberlin auch gehabt und leiden im Prinzip auch strukturell immer noch darunter.
Aber quasi ist so eine Hälfte der Stadt hat Straßenbahnen, die andere hat es halt nicht, weil sie der Meinung waren, das brauchen wir ja alles nicht mehr.
Also man hat sich da irgendwie sehr verleiten lassen und natürlich spielt das Automobil in Deutschland nochmal eine besondere Rolle, aber generell ist natürlich Transport etwas, wo man auch merkt, dass andere Städte im internationalen Vergleich da gerade so mit Siebenmeilenstiefeln unterwegs sind.
Und sich, was weiß ich, chinesische Städte schaffen es halt innerhalb von 10 Jahren sich sozusagen aus dem Nichts U-Bahn-Netze zuzulegen, die irgendwie das, was wir so in Deutschland haben, um ein Vielfaches übersteigen.
Elektromobilität zieht ein und jetzt natürlich auch andere Konzepte.
Ohne jetzt zu viel vorher schon zu erzählen, welche Bedeutung hat Verkehr also aus deiner Perspektive und welche Rolle spielt das auch konkret jetzt hier in der Forschung?
Ja, ein riesiges Thema.
Wir durften, ich hatte das vormals schon erwähnt, uns mal 3-4 Jahre in dem sogenannten BeMobility Projekt damit beschäftigen, wie eigentlich Elektromobilität in die Stadt Einzug halten kann.
Da ging es tatsächlich ganz oft auch um das Problem, wie überhaupt die Ladestruktur in Städte eingeführt werden kann, was unglaublich schwierig ist.
Und teilweise gab es Genehmigungszeiten von bis zu zwei Jahren für eine Ladesäule.
Und dass man,  apropos Geschwindigkeit, damit natürlich keine Infrastruktur ausrollen kann, die schnell in einem viel höheren Maße Elektromobilität attraktiv macht, das ist völlig klar.
Ich glaube, der Verkehr ist insofern auch eng mit den zukünftigen Weisen, wie wir arbeiten werden, verbunden.
Also momentan ist der Verkehr ja auch deswegen ein Problem, weil ich hatte eben schon Neuhohenschönhausen erwähnt, da wird nicht gearbeitet, da wird geschlafen und gelebt.
Das heißt, da wurde auch noch ordentlich Parkraum vorgehalten.
Die arbeitenden Menschen da verlassen morgens das Viertel und fahren wo auch immer hin zum Arbeiten und kommen dann wieder.
Eigentlich mehr so Pendler schon.
Richtig. Aber Pendelverkehr ist natürlich auch das, was gerade die Radialen unserer Stadt dann zumacht.
Da geht eigentlich jetzt hier in Berlin kaum noch etwas, das erleben wir alle tagtäglich morgens und abends nochmal.
An der Stelle ist es ganz spannend, inwieweit neue Produktionsformen eigentlich andere Arten und Weisen der Städte, andere Mischungsnutzungen ermöglichen.
So dass man vielleicht weniger sogenannte Trips generiert.
Also dass das die Notwendigkeit, in die Stadt zu pendeln, einfach geringer wird.
Und ich glaube, da gibt es ganz spannende Dinge, die gerade in der digitalen Produktion und im Manufactoring, digital manufactoring andere Räume ermöglichen.
Vormals, es wird sicherlich auch in der Zukunft noch große Fabriken geben, die irgendwann irgendwo außerhalb der Stadt liegen, weniger in der Stadt.
Aber es gibt halt zunehmend auch Betriebe, die mittels, auch unter Einsatz von Hightech, in kleineren Räumen in der Stadt produzieren können, im Verbund produzieren können.
Das muss nicht alles an einem Standort sein.
Die produzieren dann auch leiser, sauberer, also in vielerlei Hinsicht kann die Digitalisierung glaube ich in dem Bereich auch dazu führen, dass Nutzungen in Städte wieder einziehen, die vorher so einfach nicht denkbar waren.
Und an der Stelle wiederum kann man dann sagen, wenn man das strategisch angeht und auch ermöglicht, dass solche Räume vorgehalten werden, auch vielleicht sogar in Wohnquartieren, dann erzeugt man letztendlich einen Kontext, wo weniger Verkehr notwendig ist.
Wenn du sagst Räume, was meinst du damit genau?
Also in diesem Falle, wenn man in dem Maßstab das reflektiert, dann würde ich sagen, geht es sicher um Nachbarschaften oder größere Nachbarschaften.
Also Neuhohenschönhausen,um bei dem Beispiel zu bleiben, da sind über 40.000 Leute, das ist eigentlich per Definition schon eine kleine Stadt für sich.
Da wird jetzt direkt nebenan ein sogenannte CleanTechPark geplant.
Das ist also ein ganz klassisches Industrieareal, was freigehalten wird für Industrienutzung.
Frage ist, brauchen wir in den nächsten 10-20 Jahren eigentlich noch so explizite Trennungen oder können wir das besser miteinander verbinden, so dass attraktive Mischnutzungen in Städten möglich werden.
Und gleichzeitig kommt auch da ja mit ins Spiel, dass die Leute – also meistens handelt es sich ja um Hightech, das heißt die wiederum brauchen sehr hoch ausgebildete Mitarbeiter, und diese Mitarbeiter wiederum haben Vorstellungen von einem Leben, dass sie halt nicht irgendwo raus ins Land pendeln und dann zurückkommen.
Sondern die wünschen sich möglichst nahe an ihrer Arbeit, aber gleichzeitig möglichst nah an städtischen Infrastrukturen zu leben.
Weil das einfach momentan die Art und Weise ist, wie wir leben wollen.
Zugang zu kulturellen Einrichtungen und so weiter und so fort.
Das heißt, idealerweise haben wir 20 Minuten maximal mit dem Fahrrad zu fahren und können auf dem Weg auch noch unsere Kinder zur Kita bringen und dann wieder abholen.
Und das Kino ist auch gleich um die Ecke.
Das Kino ist auch gleich um die Ecke.
Und das erzeugt aber natürlich einen Druck, Städte anders zu mischen, so dass das auch machbar wird.
Ist denn das ein Trend?
Ich meine, ist das etwas, was jetzt so allen irgendwie klar ist oder muss man das irgendwie Leuten noch erklären, dass 70er Jahre Wohnsilos keine gute Idee sind?
Ich glaube, die Erkenntnis ist da.
Die Schwierigkeit ist eher, das umzusetzen.
Also Stadtplanung hat ganz lange Planungshorizonte oder hatte die.
Und genau das ist das Thema, was mich interessiert.
Städtische Formen verändern sich grundsätzlich, ich weiß nicht 80-100 Jahre oder so.
Infrastruktur rechnet man zumindest meistens auf 20 Jahre.
Meistens sind Infrastrukturen, die ja auch Stadt ermöglichen oder bestimmte Kapazitäten in Städten ermöglichen, auch längerfristig verfügbar.
Aber es ist halt nicht so einfach mal über Nacht zu verändern.
Wenn man sich so ein bisschen die Zukunftsvisionen der 80er Jahre anguckt oder 90er Jahre und die Filme von damals, Bladerunner oder das Fünfte Element, dann haben die alle Zukunftsvisionen von heute mehr oder weniger dargestellt, die städtisch völlig anders aussahen.
Riesige Häuserschluchten und fliegende Autos dazwischen, weiß der Himmel.
Wenn man aber tatsächlich mal anguckt, wie sich diese Städte verändert haben seitdem, ist das marginal.
Was sich verändert ist, wie wir sie benutzen.
Und insofern ist Stadtplanung eigentlich mehr von der Erneuerung der Betriebssysteme unserer Smartphones getrieben, als von irgendwelchen Zukunftsvisionen über ein anderes räumliches Verständnis wie wir leben wollen.
Weil es einfach billiger ist.
Also ein Smartphone zu kaufen ist einfach billiger, das Operation System einfach abzudaten, was dann plötzlich neue Funktionen kann, wie man die Stadt anders benutzen kann.
Wie diese räumliche Stadt aber darauf reagiert, das ist die Frage, die mich interessiert.
Sprich, der Aspekt Digitalisierung jetzt auch, steht ja auch in der Professur so mit drin, ist quasi auch die Digitalisierung explizit als Werkzeug benutzen, um sozusagen das was da ist auch einfach anders zum Einsatz zu bringen.
Ist nicht alles jetzt unbedingt immer um großflächige Umbauten und wir bauen das jetzt mal ganz anders von Vornherein, auch wenn das wünschenswert wäre.
Dass man irgendwie versucht, quasi zu reagieren, also Resilienz zu zeigen, unter Ausnutzung digitaler Optionen?
Also die Digitalisierung in der Stadt hat glaube ich zwei Ebenen, die man berücksichtigen muss.
Zum einen ist es, wie wir Städte betreiben und zum anderen wie wir sie planen.
Und für beides kann Digitalisierung glaube ich auch ja bis hin zu revolutionären Veränderungen mit sich bringen.
Also bleiben wir erst mal bei der Planung, wir sind Stadtplaner oder Architekten sind Planer.
Das muss auch in der Zukunft so bleiben, dass Vorhaben geplant werden müssen.
Aber wir können das zukünftig und auch schon jetzt auf einem viel höheren Verständnis der Stadt.
Also es gibt jetzt schon ganz völlig andere Wege, auf Daten der Stadt zuzugreifen und sie zu verstehen, als wir das noch vor 10 Jahren hatten wahrscheinlich oder 20 Jahren.
Zum Beispiel?
Also gerade in der Stadtplanung denke ich mal ist die GIS, also GeoInformationSystems, ganz wichtig gewesen.
Die einfach Daten in Planungen vorhalten, nicht nur räumliche Daten, sondern auch Klimadaten, soziale Daten, ökonomische Daten vorhalten, die man vorher, wenn überhaupt, äußerst mühsam recherchieren musste.
Das ist jetzt ready at your fingertips, wie man in England sagen würde.
Und das entwickelt sich insofern auch noch spannend, dass wir nicht nur jetzt verstehen, wie die Stadt jetzt ist, sondern dass Digitalisierung auch durch die zukünftigen Modellierungsmöglichkeiten erlaubt, dass wir bestimmte Maßnahmen, die wir ergreifen oder deren Auswirkungen viel besser vorher schon verstehen können.
Also wir können modellieren, welche Auswirkung hat es, wenn wir die Straße hier auf 30 km/h reduzieren.
Oder wenn wir hier ein Gebäude machen, welcher Druck wird da durch zusätzliche Verkehrsströme oder zusätzliche Menschen entstehen und so weiter.
Also wir reden jetzt von einer richtigen Simulation?
Ja genau. Wir verstehen die Daten jetzt viel besser, wo sind die Menschen, wo sind die Autos, wo sind die Abwasser, wo ist das Wasser, wo kommt die Elektrizität her?
Wir können die Maßnahmen, die wir in der Stadtentwicklung planen, viel besser im Kontext verstehen, aber auch viel besser in einem zukünftigen Kontext verstehen.
Ist das jetzt nur so ein theoretisches Konstrukt oder wird das getan, macht ihr das?
Das passiert zunehmend, aber da erwarte ich noch ganz große Innovationsschübe in der Zukunft.
Ich meine, in welchem … ich meine, in einem bestimmten Rahmen wird das sicherlich getan.
Ich habe da jetzt nicht so viel Einblick, aber ich würde mal so sagen, Ampeln müssen ja schon auch irgendwie durch Simulation so ein bisschen darauf hin getestet werden, ob sie zumindest schon mal die Verkehrsflüsse, wie man sie erwartet, richtig regeln.
Ob das dann so gelingt, ist ja nochmal die andere Sache.
Wenn man aber hin will zu so einem Stadtbetriebssystem oder Stadtsimulationssystem, dann muss man ja im Prinzip noch sehr viel mehr mit reinnehmen.
Fußgänger, Verkehr, also nicht nur die ganze Verkehrsdynamik, sondern eben auch andere Vorfälle, Wetter, Klima, all solche Aspekte.
Weil ein schöner warmer Tag erzeugt natürlich auf einmal ganz andere Verkehrsströme als ein Regentag.
Wird das irgendwie schon gemacht?
Also gibt es irgendwo schon so eine Stadt quasi als simulierter Kosmos oder ist das noch Zukunftsmusik?
Ich würde sagen, das ist noch Zukunftsmusik, aber zum Beispiel hat vor gar nicht so langer Zeit die Firma Sidewalk Labs, eine Tochterfirma von Google, kundgegeben, dass sie in Toronto einen Stadtteil bauen möchte, der eigentlich diese Modellierungswerkzeuge, die Sensorik, die heutzutage möglich ist, einmal wirklich bauen möchte und verstehen, welche Auswirkungen das hat und haben kann auf Stadtentwicklung.
Das hat sicherlich viele sehr bedenkliche auch Fragestellungen.
Datensicherheit, wie sehr möchten wir überhaupt verfolgt sein im digitalen Kosmos?
Wie kontrolliert werden dadurch unsere Wege?
Ich meine, unsere Wege zu verstehen in der Stadt ist nicht wahnsinnig kompliziert. Also wir sind relativ gut vorhersehbar.
Wenn wir alle mal ganz ehrlich sind, ist unser Tagesablauf wahrscheinlich mindestens an Werktagen immer sehr ähnlich.
War vielleicht schon mal noch vorhersagbarer, als es jetzt ist, mit anderen Arbeitsformen, aber im Grunde genommen ist es nicht wahnsinnig schwierig, wenn man Zugang zu den Geodaten hat.
Dann auch zu sagen, okay …
Zu welchen Geodaten?
Wo du in diesem Falle warst und daraus kann man relativ gut simulieren, wo du am nächsten Dienstag sein wirst.
Na gut, aber diese Daten muss man auch erst mal kriegen.
Richtig.
Also ich meine, die Smartphonehersteller haben die mindestens in anonymisierter Form wahrscheinlich auch teilweise in nicht ganz so anonymisierter Form.
Das wird ja auch lange schon zum Einsatz gebracht für Navigationssysteme etc., die quasi so die typische Verkehrsbelastung auf Straßen dadurch vorhersagen, dass man im Prinzip sich einfach mal anschaut, wo bewegen sich denn diese ganzen Smartphones hin mit mehr als 20 km/h.
Dann weiß man halt, wo ein Auto fährt, das wird ja schon sehr sehr sehr lange getan.
Nur das sind natürlich dann alles Daten, auf die zunächst erst einmal nur private Unternehmen Zugriff haben.
Wie kann jetzt man auf stadtplanerischer Ebene da vorankommen?
Naja die Zugänglichkeit, also das ist tatsächlich einer der ganz ganz kritischen Punkte, überhaupt wie funktioniert Stadt?
Momentan haben wir den Begriff der Daseinsvorsorge, die Daseinsvorsorge liegt natürlich bei der Administration, bei unseren gewählten Vertretern eigentlich.
Ich würde sagen, wir sind hier bei dem Thema Transport und Mobilität.
Die Firma Google hat sicherlich viel bessere Daten als alle Städte oder alle Stadtverwaltungen der Welt.
Man kann entsprechend Verkehrsflüsse verstehen, aber natürlich auch beeinflussen.
Also welche Algorithmen setzen eigentlich wie wir Umleitungen machen?
Und ist es akzeptabel, dass so eine Umleitung einfach immer nur der schnellste Weg ist, was aber vielleicht dann bedeutet, dass das durch eine verkehrsberuhigte Zone geht das Ganze.
Ich würde mal sagen, von der Stadtqualitätsfrage her gesehen ist das nicht akzeptabel, aber es passiert.
Und an der Stelle sind unsere Ampeln eben nicht so klug oder noch nicht so klug, vielleicht gleichzeitig unseren Stadtentwicklungszielen, also den gemeinschaftlich befundenen Stadtentwicklungszielen zu entsprechen, sondern die funktionieren stur immer weiter und die Algorithmen berechnen, okay hier ist der schnellste Weg.
Da haben wir Konflikte, die wir glaube ich noch fast gesellschaftlich überhaupt erst mal debattieren müssen.
Wie weit wollen wir uns abhängig machen von unserer Systemen?
Wie weit ist das okay, dass Google … also die besten Daten zu haben per se ist ja nicht falsch, aber was machen sie denn damit?
Und wie da wie gesagt, Administration, also die öffentliche Hand und die private Hand zusammenkommt, mache ich mir tatsächlich auch Sorgen.
Das passiert nicht in einer Geschwindigkeit, wo ich …
Das ist natürlich auch so ein bisschen so eine deutsche Bedenkenträger-Diskussion, dass man sozusagen jetzt irgendwie neue Chancen versucht sozusagen klarzumachen.
Und so jetzt gucken wir doch mal, ob wir das simulieren können und dann scheitern wir sozusagen schon an der Haustür mit Datenschutzbedenken, die natürlich absolut berechtigt sind, für die es ja aber auch schon jetzt ganz interessante Lösungen gibt, was so Datensammlungen betrifft, wie man sozusagen Daten halbwegs akkurat halten kann, aber sie dabei trotzdem deanonymisiert.
Apple hat ja so ein ähnliches Prinzip in seinem iPhone-System, dass sie quasi zwar viele Daten sammeln, aber im Prinzip die Herkunft verschleiern, indem sie einfach bewusst Fehler einbauen, die sich aber dann so verteilen, dass die Gesamtaussage immer noch stimmt.
Ich wollte nochmal kurz so auf die Chancen, also das mal einfach so ein bisschen überdreht und mal sich ein ideales System vorstellt.
Vielleicht bleiben wir auch einfach mal bei Berlin, weil es so schön einfach ist.
Wie müsste man denn eigentlich rangehen?
Also wie kriegt man diese Stadt simuliert?
Weil ich meine dieses, wir wissen ja eigentlich schon alles und wir sagen das voraus, ist natürlich auch so ein Bios in dem Moment, dass man sagt, naja wir wissen ja auch wie es ist.
Die Leute gehen zur Arbeit, und fertig.
Kann aber natürlich auch ganz gut sein, dass wenn man sich das mal genau anschaut, dass man so feststellt, mhm das stimmt zwar irgendwie auch, aber es gibt hier noch 2-3 andere Faktoren, die wir eigentlich noch überhaupt nicht auf dem Zeiger haben, die sich aber ganz klar in den Daten zeigen, die vielleicht auch einiges erklären, warum bestimmte Konzepte so bisher noch nicht funktioniert haben.
Ich glaube an der Stelle können wir zurück zu dem Punkt, inwieweit man überhaupt Stadtentwicklung planen kann, selbst wenn wir unbegrenzte Firepower durch künstliche Intelligenz haben und wirklich auf dem Jetzt-Verständnis von städtischen Prozessen simulieren können, wie sich das unter den gleichen Bedingungen in den nächsten 15 Jahren entwickeln wird.
Was dabei gerne vergessen wird, dass es eben nicht, wie ich vorher gesagt habe, ein Bauprojekt ist, sondern da haben wir in diesem Zeitraum verschiedene Regierungen, da haben wir verschiedene Entwicklungen innerhalb von Quartieren.
Ein Quartier kann sich heutzutage relativ schnell verändern, ist plötzlich eine ganz andere Klientel da oder andere Stimmen werden wichtig.
Dann haben wir eine Geflüchtetenwelle, die mit berücksichtigt werden muss, wie integrieren wir die, die auch hier ganz schnell passiert ist und unsere Systeme sicherlich erst mal gesprengt hat oder so herausgefordert hat, dass sie nur mit dem tollen Einsatz von Freiwilligen funktionierte.
Ich bezweifle, selbst wenn wir dieses Instrument hätten, also das zukunftsmodelling-Maschine, dass die uns eben diese Zukunft berechnen könnte.
Was sie kann ist einfach Entwicklungsszenarien aufzeigen.
Und in diesen Entwicklungsszenarien müssen wir aber immer mitfahren, wie eigentlich die Bürger und die Nutzer unserer Stadt darüber denken.
Das heißt, es muss eigentlich immer bei diesen Technologien mitgefahren werden ein Partizipationsprozess.
Man muss das immer wieder abgleichen.
Und das ist schwer vorhersehbar, denke ich mal.
Ich meine, die Simulation einer möglichen Zukunft ist ja das eine und das Abbilden der aktuellen Realität ist das andere.
Und ich meine, wenn man jetzt mal so diesen Google Sidewalk-Ansatz und so weiter geht, da mag zwar eine Zukunftsplanung letzten Endes natürlich dabei sein, aber sie basiert ja vor allem erst mal auf so einer mehr oder weniger umfassenden Feststellungen des Ist-Zustandes.
Also man nimmt einfach viele Daten, die reale Daten über wie läuft es jetzt denn gerade beschreiben und daraus kann man ja dann sozusagen meinetwegen auch über Partizipation dann eben den nächsten Schritt gehen.
Aber man müsste ja überhaupt erst mal an diesen Punkt kommen, dass man auch zuverlässige Daten hat.
Wie viel weiß denn die Stadt über die Stadt?
Das ist noch relativ wenig, glaube ich.
Und vor allen Dingen ist die Frage, welche Datensätze sind das denn?
Auch heutzutage, Berlin hat eigentlich ein ganz schönes auch öffentliches GIS-System, also ein Geoinformationssystem, der FIS-Broker, wo man relativ hohe Datenverfügbarkeit hat.
Also die öffentliche Hand macht da die Daten entsprechend öffentlich und oftmals sind diese Daten dann aber 4-7 Jahre alt.
Und dann kann man sich fragen, welchen Aussagewert haben sie denn noch?
An der Stelle wird Digitalisierung sicherlich dazu führen, dass wir viel bessere Jetztzeitdaten bekommen.
Also ich glaube, da ist noch einiges aufzuholen.
Aber wenn wir das haben, heißt das ja immer noch nicht, dass wir jetzt komplett zufrieden sind mit, wie wir leben, sondern wir haben eine ganze Menge Probleme, die wir lösen müssen.
Eine ganze Menge Herausforderungen, die wir lösen müssen.
Wie können wir nachhaltiger leben?
Wie können wir den Klimaschutzzielen entsprechen und so weiter und so fort.
Wir wissen eigentlich jetzt schon, dass wir nicht so weiter bauen können unsere Städte, wie wir es bisher getan haben.
Also wir müssen nicht nur den Jetzt-Zustand verstehen, sondern wir müssen sagen, unter bestimmten Parametern müssen wir die Stadt verändern.
Und das ist halt ein sehr träges Geschehen per Definition von Stadt.
Weil sich Stadtraum, Infrastrukturen, wie ich vorhin schon meinte, irgendwie nur sehr träge verändern lassen.
Man hat da ganz viele Pfadabhängigkeiten, die man nicht einfach komplett über den Haufen werfen kann.
Und das zu simulieren glaube ich, da haben wir tatsächlich, du sprachst von den Chancen, die es hat, völlig andere Instrumente.
Also manchmal vergleiche ich das so ein bisschen wie Operieren am offenen Herzen.
Also vorher waren das Planungsverständnisse von Stadt, beruhend auf Erfahrungen, ja auch immer auf Daten, aber letztendlich wirklich mit den Daten, die wir heute haben, fast lächerlich.
So dass man nach vorne planen musste und Setzungen machen musste.
Heutzutage ist es eher so wie ein Chirurg, der einen Körper öffnet, das macht er ja auch nicht völlig ungeplant, sondern er weiß, was da passiert, aber er kriegt ein Jetztzeit-Feedback von sei es der Sauerstoffsättigung des Blutes bis hin zum Puls, was auch immer, welche Lebenszeichen das sind.
Und ich denke, wir kommen mehr in eine Situation, wo ein Planer heutzutage quasi simulieren kann, wenn ich das mache, dann ist es hochwahrscheinlich, dass das das das und das passiert.
Das muss dann aber erst mal analysiert werden, inwieweit entspricht das eigentlich den Zielen, die wir verfolgen müssen und wollen.
Und dann muss man natürlich auch noch die Leute fragen, die da wohnen.
Und das zusammenzubringen denke ich mal da hilft diese Stimulierung und die Modellierung ungemein.
Das ist auch immer ein Übersetzungsprozess, der noch geleistet werden muss, denn es gibt kaum Dinge, die komplexer sind, glaube ich, als städtisches Leben.
Das aber den Bürgern zu kommunizieren, welche Auswirkungen das hat, ist halt auch immer eine Übersetzungsarbeit dabei.
Denn einfach nur die Simulation ihnen vor die Nase zu legen oder irgendwelche Pläne, das werden viele Leute vielleicht anfänglich begreifen, aber das alles zusammenzubringen, welche Konsequenzen das hat, ist auch für Spezialisten nicht ganz einfach.
Jetzt wird ja, um vielleicht nochmal auf den Verkehr zurückzukommen, der zweifelsohne eine große Rolle spielt und der vor allem auch viel in der Diskussion ist gerade, was sind denn da so deine Erwartungen und Beobachtungen?
Also was steht denn jetzt an?
Was kann quasi der Verkehr dazu beitragen, dass die urbane Resilienz voranschreitet?
Ich glaube ich würde das andersrum aufsetzen.
Wir müsse uns an der Stelle fragen, wie sollen unsere Städte a) funktionieren und b) aussehen, welche Qualität müssen sie haben?
Und welche Verkehrsräume brauchen wir dafür?
Und welche Technologien können wir einsetzen, um diese Ziele zu erreichen?
Ich denke mal, wie du vorhin völlig richtig gesagt hast, wir leben eigentlich fast alle in Städten, die für Verkehr gebaut worden sind.
In den USA noch viel mehr als hier, wo wir die historischen Stadtkerne haben, die aber natürlich auch immer um logistische Flüsse herum geplant wurden, aber nicht das Auto per se.
Da haben wir Glück in vielerlei Hinsicht.
Denn ich glaube die Resilienz von teilweise amerikanischen Städten, die wirklich für das Auto geplant sind, ist nur sehr begrenzt.
Die zu verändern und eine entsprechende Dichte herzustellen und kritische Massen für andere Formen des Verkehrs, wird schwierig.
Also da möchte ich nicht unbedingt in deren Haut stecken.
Wir in Europa haben viel dichtere Städte, letztendlich bedingt durch die Geschichte dieser Städte.
So da müssen wir uns aber fragen, was können wir denn mit diesen Stadträumen besseres machen, als lauter Parkplätze da zu haben?
Und an der Stelle haben wir dann die Chancen des Carsharings zum Beispiel.
Das war ein großer Forschungsbestandteil dieses BeMobility-Projektes.
Aber dann zukünftig auch dem autonomen Fahren.
Also es gibt Aussagen, die sagen, ein voll genutztes Carsharing-Auto kann bis zu acht, also die Zahlen schwanken etwas zwischen 7 und 10 oder 12 glaube ich, private Autos ersetzen.
Weil ein privates Auto, wie wir jetzt alle wissen, wird …
… wird selten benutzt.
Selten benutzt.
Morgens mal, abends mal, dazwischen steht es irgendwo rum.
Und das bedingt natürlich die Qualität unserer Straßenräume.
Ich muss hier nur einmal aus dem Fenster gucken, wir sind hier im Prenzlberg, da sehe ich eigentlich vornehmlich erst mal nur Autos stehen.
Und da denke ich mal wird uns schnell viel besseres einfallen.
Da gibt es auch schon eine ganze Menge Projekte.
Aber Verkehrsberuhigung per se, also einfach die zu verbannen alleine, kann es ja nicht sein, denn wir müssen weiterhin ja den Leuten ermöglichen, sich so zu bewegen, wie sie das wollen.
Auch idealerweise so intuitiv.
Und da brauchen wir multimodale Mobilitätskonzepte, die im Grunde genommen mit der Intuitivität des Autos konkurrieren können.
Wir setzen uns morgens da rein und fahren von A nach B in der Annahme, das ist die glatteste und einfachste Art und Weise von A nach B zu kommen.
Vielleicht noch C ist der Kindergarten.
Das Ganze mit einer Kombination von weiß nicht Carsharing, Bikesharing, Bussen, Bahnen, wie auch immer hinzulegen, das geht vielleicht, aber oftmals wird uns das gar nicht richtig gezeigt.
Also bis heute gibt es keine wirklich konkurrenzfähigen, würde ich mal sagen, Apps, die mir sagen, okay wenn du jetzt aufbrichst, basierend live auf den Daten und der Situation des Verkehrs da draußen, wenn du das und das Verkehrsmittel nimmst, bist du übrigens schneller.
Und womöglich ist es auch noch billiger.
Das gibt es nicht.
Aber multimodale Mobilitätskonzepte müssen das vorhalten.
Oder umgekehrt …
Beißt sich das an der Stelle vielleicht auch so mit dem privatwirtschaftlichen Ansatz, den man jetzt hinter Carsharing primär noch hat?
Also ich war jetzt gerade in Paris und da habe ich gesehen, Paris wird halt auch richtig Elektroautos von der Stadt quasi betrieben.
Bei den Fahrrädern ist es ein bisschen komplizierter, das habe ich nicht so ganz verstanden.
Aber mir scheint, dass in manchen Städten sehr viel mehr auf so ein kommunales System gesetzt wird, wo natürlich ein ganz anderer Interessenausgleich ist.
Da hat quasi ja die Stadt auch dieses Interesse mit, hier nimm mal die optimale Kombination und mir ist jetzt eigentlich egal, ob du irgendwie hier mit der großen Metro fährst, mit der U-Bahn, mit dem Bus oder eben mit so einem gemieteten Auto oder Fahrrad.
Während hier oft die Dinge ja noch so ein bisschen zueinander in Konkurrenz stehen so.
Ja fahre hier mit diesem Elektromoped, weil dann bist du 10 Cent billiger, als wenn du jetzt mit der Straßenbahn fährst.
Was interessanterweise oftmals nicht ausschlaggebend ist für die Wahl des Verkehrsmittels.
Also wenn es nur 10 Cent sind, dann ist es in den meisten Fällen den Leuten egal.
Keiner rechnet so genau.
Sondern da gibt es auch viele interessante Studien, die dann sagen, dann regiert doch eher die vermutliche Bequemlichkeit oder die angenommene Bequemlichkeit, sich einfach doch ins Auto zu setzen, man steht dann halt doch wieder am Funkturmkreuz oder was auch immer.
Aber trotzdem empfehlen sich die Systeme ja nicht gegenseitig.
Nein und an der Stelle ist es genauso, dass wir nicht einfach nur Alternativen aufzeigen müssen, sondern die müssen halt mit Algorithmen gepaart werden, die unseren größeren Stadtentwicklungszielen entsprechen.
Also Carsharing ist dann gut, wenn es Individualverkehr ersetzt und entsprechend weniger Privatautos vielleicht generiert, die irgendwo nur rumstehen.
Wenn aber Carsharing anfängt, die öffentlichen Verkehrsmitteln und mit denen zu konkurrieren, und denn womöglich sogar Fahrgäste zu klauen hätte ich jetzt fast gesagt, da zu konkurrieren und die Zahlen zu reduzieren, dann kann das nicht Sinn der Sache sein.
Es gibt auch, wenn wir jetzt in die Zukunft gucken und das autonome Fahren angucken, gibt es Leute, die dann sagen, wir wollen nur noch autonomes Fahren haben, weil das so herrlich bequem ist.
Da gibt es sogar irgendwelche Studien, die sagen, die autonomen Autos sind ja auch sehr viel kleiner, wäre es nicht herrlich, wenn wir Gebäude bauen, wo ein Elektroauto eigentlich vor meiner Haustür steht, schon im Gebäude im 4. Geschoss, weil es da hin kann.
Also die Fahrstühle können das, das Ding ist elektrisch, hat keine Abgase, es holt mich da ab, nimmt mich runter in den Straßenraum, fährt mich irgendwo hin und spuckt mich auf der anderen Seite in dem Büro wieder aus.
Der universelle Rollstuhl sozusagen.
Genau, theoretisch denkbar.
Das ist natürlich für die Qualität der Stadt eine Katastrophe, da begegnet sich ja niemand mehr.
Und schon gar nicht zufällig.
Aber was ich eigentlich sagen wollte, wenn das so wäre, dann hätten wir mehr Verkehr und nicht weniger.
Also in der irrigen Annahme, dass das bequemer ist, als sich in die U-Bahn oder S-Bahn zu setzen.
Also die Kapazitäten der S-Bahnen und U-Bahnen können wir mit so was nicht ersetzen und sollten wir auch nicht ersetzen.
Und an der Stelle muss man immer auch wie gesagt sich fragen, welchen Zielen der Stadtentwicklung folgen wir eigentlich?
Mal ganz ketzerisch gefragt, also kann überhaupt so ein privatwirtschaftliches Modell an der Stelle wirklich greifen?
Weil gerade auch beim Carsharing ist natürlich das Problem, man steht immer in diesem Konflikt, also jetzt als Betreiber, man will natürlich nicht mehr Autos auf die Straße stellen, als jetzt auch wirklich nachgefragt wird.
Klar, man muss so ein gewisses Mindestangebot irgendwie erst mal bieten, aber da sind ja auch schon so einige so ein bisschen dran gescheitert, dass dann halt der Return an Investment halt nicht so groß ist.
Während man natürlich, wenn man jetzt da so kommunal oder sogar auf Bundesebene als Stadt oder Staat darüber nachdenkt, natürlich da ganz anders agieren kann.
Sagen kann, naja wir schaffen jetzt aber hier ein Mobilitätsangebot und das ist dann auch so verfügbar und hat so viel Überkapazität, dass es sozusagen auch jederzeit zugreifbar ist.
Klar, die Apps sind toll, weil sie einem sagen, wo das Ding ist.
Aber wenn ich halt drei Kilometer laufen muss bis zum nächsten Auto, ist das für mich natürlich auch keine Option.
Richtig. Genau da zählt diese Intuitivität, von der ich sprach, diese Bequemlichkeit.
Wenn das zu weit weg ist, dann setze ich mich sofort in mein Auto.
Das ist in der Tat eine schwierige Frage und ich denke mal, da erleben wir auch momentan so ein bisschen Aufwachen auf Seite der öffentlichen Verkehrsmittelträger.
Die am Anfang das so eine bisschen eher den Privaten überlassen haben.
Ich glaube, wenn ich das richtig beobachte, auch hier bei der BVG, beschäftigen die sich jetzt schon sehr intensiv auch mit multimodalen Konzepten, also jenseits der Verkehrsmittel, die sie ohnehin schon hatten.
Die Deutsche Bahn genauso, also das BeMobility-Projekt haben wir ganz eng zusammen mit den entsprechenden RND-Institutionen der Deutschen Bahn gemacht, weil die weiß, es ist mehr als Zug.
Ich meine, die Deutsche Bahn hat sowieso schon fast alle oder hat schon alle Verkehrsmittel.
Da ist Carsharing, da sind die Fahrräder mit drin.
Das ergänzt sich halt auch sehr schön an vielen Stellen.
Richtig, aber da ist man natürlich immer so ein bisschen … letztendlich kommt es wie du sagst, Return of Investment.
Also wo kann ich investieren und die Öffentlichen müssen dann natürlich immer auch beweisen, dass es ein Investment ist, was funktioniert.
Oftmals ist es ja aber auch so, dass bei den öffentlichen Verkehrsträgern man auch nach Wirtschaftlichkeit guckt.
Wo dann eigentlich… und das per Definition guckt dann auf das bestehende System und weniger, wie können diese Systeme eigentlich angepasst werden auf die Herausforderungen der Zukunft?
Das sind dann Investitionen, die ganz fairerweise muss man sagen, aus dem Eigenbetrieb heraus nicht einfach passieren können.
Und an der Stelle müssen Regierungen sich dann fragen, wo investieren wir?
Ich meine, oft ist ja öffentlicher Nahverkehr auch im Wesentlichen eine kommunale Beauftragung.
Das heißt, die Stadt definiert eben auch bestimmte Erreichbarkeitsziele und Versorgungsgüten bestimmter Regionen und Strecken.
Auch wenn sie dann eben nicht wirtschaftlich betrieben werden können, was den eigentlichen Betrieb betrifft, rechnet ja eine Stadt, eine Kommune das alles anders zusammen.
Weil es sozusagen Arbeitsplätze verbindet, weil es irgendwie Dörfer unterstützt, weil es irgendwie neue Zentren und Oberzentren schafft, die so vielleicht sonst nicht entstehen würden.
All diese ganzen Parameter kommen ja noch mit dazu, wo ein reiner Mobilitätsanbieter natürlich nur seinen eigenen Betrieb an der Stelle im Blick hat.
Richtig, und da müssen Geschäftsmodelle glaube ich anders zusammenkommen.
Und nicht nur innerhalb der Privatwirtschaft.
Das war ja auch noch bis vor fünf Jahren undenkbar, dass die Automobilhersteller plötzlich große Flotten vorhalten.
Also plötzlich ein Geschäftsmodell ist, die nicht zu verkaufen, sondern selber zu haben und den Service Fahren anzubieten.
Da tut sich eine Menge.
Das muss sich aber auch denke ich mal neu verbinden mit öffentlichen Interessen und entsprechenden Investitionen.
Und das glaube ich, an der Stelle kann Digitalisierung und eben diese Modellierung, von der wir schon sprachen, glaube ich ganz viel leisten, insofern dass sie diese Entwicklungskorridore mit einer ganz anderen Evidenzbasis hinterlegen.
Denn andernfalls ist es natürlich auch ganz schnell so, wenn es mal einen innovativen Verkehrsbetrieb gibt, der sagt, wir investieren jetzt einfach mal in die Richtung und wir machen das auch nicht nur in Form eines Pilotprojektes, das vielleicht ganz spannend ist, aber keine großen Auswirkungen haben wird, weil wir andere kritische Massen brauchen, um es grundlegend zu verändern.
Wenn das denn mal schiefgeht oder mal nicht genauso kommt, wie man sich das gedacht hat, ist man relativ schnell dabei, Schuldzuweisungen zu machen.
Und insofern glaube ich, ist genau da eine große Chance für digitale Stadtmodellierung.
Die digitale Stadtmodellierung der Zukunft und so auch aktuell ist da ja auch schon einiges im Wesen.
Ich meine gerade die ganze Art und Weise, wie so Gebäue gebaut werden heutzutage, ist ja schon extrem digital.
Und es gibt da diesen schönen Begriff des Building Information Modellings.
Was sozusagen als neuer Prozess in diese ganze Häuserplanung mit Einzug gehalten hat in den letzten 10 Jahren denke ich mal in etwa.
Welche Rolle spielt das und ist das etwas, worauf man aufsetzen kann?
Also in Deutschland, wenn überhaupt, zieht es gerade erst ein.
Ich durfte auch längere Zeit meines Lebens in England verbringen.
In England ist es schon, ich weiß nicht mehr die genaue Jahreszahl, aber es geht bestimmt schon knapp 10 Jahren, da gibt es da die Setzung, dass alle öffentlichen Gebäude mit Building Information Modelling passieren.
Da muss man vielleicht kurz erklären, was das ist.
Es geht im Gruden genommen nicht um ein weiteres Zeichentool, was das jetzt auch in 3D beherrscht.
Das konnte die CAD-Systeme, die Computer Edit Design-Systeme vorher auch schon.
Was jetzt passiert ist mit Building Information Modelling ist, dass man einfach den Betrieb, sowohl den Planungsprozess als auch den Bauprozess als auch den Betrieb dieser Gebäude hinterher viel besser abbilden und verbinden kann.
Sprich, einfach formuliert, wenn ich einen ersten Entwurf mache und den irgendwie digitalisiere, dann kann vielleicht alleine schon über die Kubatur verstehen, welche Energiebedarfe diese Kubatur hat im Vergleich zu einer kompakteren oder in einer aufgebrocheneren etc.
Das wusste man vorher, das sind halt vorher Erfahrungswerte gewesen basierend auf einfach Studien von entsprechenden Gebäuden.
Heutzutage könnte man das in dem Entwurfsprozess wirklich in Jetztzeit verstehen.
Wenn du das machst, dann hast du Energiekosten, die entsprechend höher oder niedriger sind.
Das heißt, der Betrieb von Gebäuden bzw. es gibt dann auch schon City-BIM, wo dann plötzlich Cluster von Gebäuden ins Spiel kommen, der Betrieb dieser Gebäude oder Cluster kann schon im Entwurfsprozess viel besser verstanden werden.
Was wiederum natürlich eine hoffentlich positive Auswirkung auf die Entwürfe hat.
Da darf nicht untergehen, dass ein Entwurf nicht nur eine rein funktionale Sache ist, dann kommen irgendwelche Wohnregale dabei raus, die vielleicht dann gut funktionieren oder auch entsprechenden Umweltvorgaben entsprechen, aber die Qualitäten müssen natürlich nach wie vor weiter gedacht werden, und an der Stelle sind natürlich in der Zukunft die Architekten ganz stark gefragt.
Aber dieser, wo vormals ich das Gefühl hatte in den letzten 20-30 Jahren, dass in so ein Bauprozess oftmals man sich zu sehr nur in den Komplexität einer Planung und des Baus befand, zieht jetzt viel mehr gleich am Anfang das Verständnis von dem Betrieb ein.
Es war leider so, wir haben das ein paar Mal versucht in den letzten 10 Jahren, das zu verstärken, dass, wenn ein Gebäude fertig ist, auch wirklich das postoperational auch zu verstehen.
Funktioniert das eigentlich so, wie wir es geplant haben?
Hat das tatsächlich die energetischen Parameter oder erfüllt das die Faktoren, die wir eigentlich berechnet haben?
Das passiert sehr sehr selten leider.
Jetzt in einem Building Information Modelling System, wo wir das von Anfang an bis in den Betrieb durchziehen, kann man das natürlich viel einfacher machen.
Also an der Stelle wird sich sehr sehr viel verändern.
Wir schreiben gerade an einem EU-Antrag, der sich genau mit diesen Systemen beschäftigt und verschiedene Digitalisierungsplattformen da auch zusammenbringen möchte.
Es geht ja darum, dass so bestehende Gebäude, also das ist ein Call, der sich mit Gebäudebestand beschäftigt, was ganz wichtig ist.
Denn wir bauen ja maximal 1-2% im Jahr Neubau neu, also neuen Buildingstock neu.
Das wird über viele Jahre dann irgendwann dazu führen, dass wir vielleicht auch diese Datensysteme, diese Livedatensysteme haben, aber das langt nicht.
Insbesondere guckt die EU auch in die östlichen Mitgliedsländer, wo noch ganz viel Bestand ist, der renoviert werden muss.
Und fragt sich jetzt, wie können wir das mit digitalen Planungswerkzeugen anders machen.
Und da geht es dann wirklich von der Aufnahme, dem Scannen, digitalen Scannen von Gebäuden bis zu BEM, ist dann Building Energy Modelling.
Bis hin zu, wenn wir dann alle diese Datensätze miteinander verknüpfen, wie können das in die Asset-Management-Systeme von Immobilienbesitzern überfordern.
Also die wiederum ermöglicht werden, einfach ihre Gebäude viel besser zu verstehen, viel besser nach vorne zu planen, wann muss ich welche Investitionen vermutlich tun, um die Energieperfomance von meinem Bestand noch zu verbessern oder hier noch Lücken zu schließen.
Da wird sich unglaublich viel tun, denke ich mal.
Und an der Stelle ist es in der ganz konkreten Bauwelt ganz spannend momentan.
Ich hör viele Architekten fluchen über solche BIM-Systeme, die dann auch auf einmal so an ganz entscheidenden Faktoren Berufsbilder schafft, die eigentlich von dem eigentlichen architekturplanerischen Business weiter entfernt sind.
Ich sage jetzt mal nicht, zu weit, aber da wird dann sozusagen schon so eine gewisse Unverbundenheit mit der Türklinke der realen beklagt.
Und dass auch hier natürlich das Problem entsteht, dass wir uns da auch in so einem extrem proprietären Zufallsraum bewegen, wo sozusagen dann dieses Wissen über unsere neuen Systeme entsteht.
Also einfach die Software-Systeme, die Datenformate, die dort verwendet werden, sich dann einfach auch nur noch auf sehr wenige Anbieter beziehen, dass es da einen Mangel an Standards gibt.
Ist das auch ein Teil der Überlegung bei euch?
Also diese Stimmen höre ich auch.
Ich halte sie nicht für gerechtfertigt.
Ich halte sie ganz im Gegenteil für eine große Chance, auch gerade für den Berufsstand der Architekten.
Denn ich durfte über die letzten 20 Jahre mit vielen auch internationalen sehr bekannten Architekten zusammenarbeiten.
Mit Foster, Grimshaw und wie sie alle heißen.
Die sehr entwurfsgetrieben waren, aber natürlich ist das alles nur bedeutsam, wenn man es auch schafft, das wirklich auf der Baustelle umzusetzen.
Deswegen in der Diskussion in der Architektur passiert ganz schnell, dass dann diese Planungswerkzeuge so als Bedrohung der Kreativität gesehen werden.
Der Architektenberuf ist glaube ich fast noch mehr als der Kreativberuf der Generalistenberuf.
Auf großen Baustellen, das erlebe ich immer noch, ich berate nebenher hier in Berlin größere Projekte.
Wenn es darum geht, komplexe Sachverhalte zusammenzubringen in einen Kontext, in einem Entwurf, also jenseits des Ästhetischen, in eine Planung.
Dann gucken alle am Tisch in Richtung des Architekten.
Ich glaube, diese Werkzeuge, die sich da ergeben, ermöglichen Architekten vielleicht ein bisschen wieder aus dieser Entwurfsnische rauszukommen und vielmehr in eine starke Position, wo vielleicht aber auch ganz viele Chancen gerade für den Entwurf sind.
Also Entwurf muss eigentlich immer… also ein Bauherr wird immer fragen, was kann denn das hinterher?
Also was kostet mich das denn, nicht nur im Bau, sondern was kostet mich das im Betrieb hinterher.
Also diese Fragen gab es immer.
Ich finde in den letzten 10-15 Jahren ist so ein bisschen in der Architektur die Diskussion, wo die Helden denn Sahadid Und Gehry waren und so weiter.
Da ist so ein bisschen hier und da aus den Augen verloren worden, dass die breiteste Masse von Gebäuden, die wir bauen, ganz profane Nutzungen haben.
Was heißt profan, aber sie sind unsere Zuhause oder sie sind unser Büro.
Es ist nicht immer ein Museum, es ist nicht immer ein Opernhaus, aber das war eine Diskussion, die das ganz stark bedingt hat, die Architekturdiskussion.
Ich denke, diese Werkzeuge können im Entwurfsprozess einem auch ganz viel Macht geben.
Eben diese Qualität von Vornherein darzustellen.
Wo es vorher einfach war für einen Bauherrn zu sagen, jaja das brauchen wir nicht.
Kann man vielleicht auch mit diesen Mitteln sagen, doch doch das brauchen wir.
Und das ist aus verschiedenen Kriterien heraus gedacht etwas, was dir einen Mehrwert – und nicht nur dir lieber Investor oder lieber Entwickler, - sondern dir lieber Nutzer am Ende einen Mehrwert generiert.
In der letzten Ausgabe hier von Forschergeist habe ich mich mit Volker Quaschnig über die Energiewende bzw. das Ausbleiben der solchen … wir warten alle noch … unterhalten.
Jetzt ist natürlich der ganze Energieteil für eine Stadt auch extrem wichtig.
Heizungs-, Strom-, Datennetze, diese ganze nicht nur digitale Infrastruktur, sondern eben vor allem auch erst mal die Energieinfrastruktur bestimmt ja auch extrem das Wie und Wann und Wo einer Stadt.
Inwiefern ist das bei euch in der Forschungsarbeit auch ein Thema?
Also ich bin kein Energiespezialist, das muss natürlich mitgedacht werden in Stadtentwicklung.
Ich glaube, was da sich ergibt in Zukunft, könnten dezentralere Strategien sein.
Das ist vielleicht auch eine zwangsläufige Konsequenz der Energiewende, dass es möglich sein muss, dezentral für bestimmte Nachbarschaften oder Quartiere andere Energieformen vorzuhalten.
Da ist Deutschland, denke ich mal, relativ weit vorne.
Das wurde losgetreten irgendwann mal von diesem Energieanspargesetz.
England war da viel viel später dran zum Beispiel.
Aber also für die Stadtentwicklung ist das schon wichtig, das zu verstehen.
Aber ich glaube, das es das grundsätzlich nur bedingt verändern wird.
Das sind dann glaube ich eher Dinge, die ganz physische Auswirkungen haben.
Also wir haben Verkehr besprochen.
Was ist öffentlicher Raum, was passiert da eigentlich?
Welche Drücker haben wir da jenseits des Verkehrs?
Wie wollen sich Leute da aufhalten?
Müssen wir nach verdichten?
Also es gibt eine große Diskussion, dass die Stadt nachverdichtet werden soll und muss.
Um die Mieten erschwinglich zu halten.
Da gibt es aber auch schon Gegenbewegungen, die sagen, nein nein wir müssen eigentlich eher polyzentrisch nachdenken, denn wenn wir die Stadt vollbauen, kann die auf Wandel nicht mehr reagieren.
Da sind wir zurück bei der Resilienz-Frage, also wenn man gar keine Reserven mehr hat für Raum, dann kann man auch auf neue Entwicklungen nur noch schwerlich reagieren.
Es sei denn man hat Stadt und Gebäude von vornherein so geplant, dass sie auch umnutzbar sind.
Das ist aber nicht einfach, aus baurechtlichen Gründen schon und einfach auch aus rechtlichen Gründen oftmals.
Aber die Energie, glaube ich, ist da nicht der wesentliche Treiber von Stadtentwicklung.
Wundert mich jetzt so ein bisschen die Aussage, weil gerade diese Dezentralität natürlich auch ganz neue Möglichkeiten bietet.
Ich meine so Versorgung, Kraftwerkstandorte, wo kriegen wir jetzt überhaupt Energie an?
Wie abhängig sind wir auch von Energiezuflüssen?
Und gerade was so Heizungssysteme betrifft, da setzt man halt weiterhin auf die aus fossilen Energiestoffen betriebene Heizungssysteme, wo halt auch immer alles hingekarrt werden muss, was teuer ist, was weitere Abhängigkeiten schafft.
Oder hat man ein Fernwärmesystem, was das schon mal abmildert, wie es ja zum Beispiel in Berlin auch teilweise der Fall ist, in anderen Städten auch.
Oder setzt man eben auch schon auf komplett neue Wohnungsbau- und Renovierungssysteme, die eben auch den Betrieb modernerer elektrobasierter Wärmepumpensysteme zum Beispiel ermöglichen.
Das sind ja auch alles Fragen, die letzten Endes auf die Wohnqualität und damit auch so auf die Wahl, wo wollen die Leute wohnen, wie wollen die Leute wohnen, einen großen Einfluss hat.
Also meine Antwort bezog sich eher auf den städtischen Maßstab, auf den Gebäudemaßstab ist das natürlich von ganz großer Auswirkung.
Aber auch da denke ich mal, in Deutschland sind wir da relativ weit vorne, zumindest im Neubau.
Auch da denke ich mal in der Renovierung, in dem Altbestand ist noch Potenzial.
Aber ich glaube dadurch, dass wir schon relativ weit vorne sind, ist, wenn mich nicht alles täuscht, glaube ich die Energiebilanz eines Gebäudes hängt heutzutage mehr davon ab, also von einem entsprechend gebauten Gebäude hängt mehr davon ab, wie wir es benutzen als wie es gebaut ist.
Also wenn man es falsch benutzt und die Fenster ständig auf hat in einem Gebäude, was eigentlich nicht dafür vorgesehen war und eigentlich ohnehin eine Zwangsbelüftung hat, aber der Nutzer es nunmal gerne hat, auch im Winter mal 10 Minuten das Fenster offen zu lassen, dann versaut das die Energiebilanz in einem Maße, das viel höhere Auswirkungen hat prozentual, als dass da noch ein Zentimeter mehr Styrodur auf der Fassade ist oder so.
Ich bezog das auf den städtischen Kontext.
Ich denke mal, in Deutschland ist die Verfügbarkeit von Energie einfach relativ gut gegeben.
Frage ist dann, ich erwähnte eben schon, es gibt auch Stimmen, die sagen, wir müssen uns eigentlich polyzentral entwickeln.
Berlin war schon mal polyzentraler als es glaube ich jetzt ist.
Wenn man so mal die Städte drumherum sich anguckt, die Rheinsbergs oder die Beelitz und wie sie alle heißen, dann erleben die gerade eine neue Blüte glaube ich.
Weil der Druck auf die Stadt, auf Berlin inzwischen so hoch ist, dass die Leute ausweichen.
Die Akzeptanz zu pendeln wird größer, auch getrieben letztendlich von der Verfügbarkeit von erschwinglichem Wohnraum.
Das tut diesen Städten gut.
Ich glaube da muss man infrastrukturell darauf reagieren.
Da gibt es ja jetzt auch schon Projekte von der Bahn, Berlin und Brandenburg mal gemeinsam neue Korridore, also strategische Planung von besseren Transportkorridoren in die Stadt und wieder raus sich vorzunehmen.
Aber ich glaube, es wird nicht wahnsinnig schwierig sein, in Rheinsberg und Beelitz die Energie vorzuhalten.
Ich glaube, im internationalen Kontext ist eine tatsächlich sehr spannende Frage.
80% der Urbanisierung, die noch stattfinden wird bis 2050, wird im informellen Kontext passieren.
Das heißt, in nicht geplanten Städten.
In Deutschland wird das nicht der Fall sein, aber wir haben zum Beispiel ein Projekt in Medellin In Kolumbien, was über die letzten 10-20 Jahre von … ich glaube 20 Jahre, von 400.000 auf über zwei Millionen gewachsen ist.
Und natürlich nicht geplant und mit entsprechender Infrastrukturvorhaltung, sondern informell.
Früher nannte man sie Slums, heute sind das informelle Settlements.
Naja es ist auch … man will da ja nicht stigmatisieren.
Und es ist gerade an der Stelle spannend zu sagen, die zukünftige Urbanisierung der Welt passiert eben nicht geplant, eben nicht im geplanten Infrastruktursektor und mit entsprechenden baulichen Regulationen drumherum.
Und wie man dort in diesen Städten Energie vorhält, nachhaltig, aus erneuerbaren Energien, also das ist natürlich ein viel spannenderes Thema.
Wie kann das gewährleistet werden, da entsprechend auch Klimaziele einhalten zu wollen?
Da wird Energie sicherlich eine viel größere Rolle noch spielen.
Medellin hat allerdings auch noch so einen schönen Verkehrsaspekt, da sind doch Seilbahnen gebaut worden in die informellen Regionen.
Um dort sozusagen einfach die auf den Hügeln entstehenden urbanen besser anbinden zu können.
Richtig, das ist ganz spannend.
Auch ein bisschen irritierend im ersten Moment, wenn man das eigentlich aus den Alpen eher aus dem touristischen Zusammenhang kennt, das als Verkehrsmittel zu sehen.
Luxemburg macht das jetzt auch gerade, auch um den Verkehr in den Griff zu kriegen.
Das ist tatsächlich, wenn man mit den Herstellern spricht, da gibt es glaube ich nur 2-3 große weltweit, Doppelmayr und Leitner heißen sie glaube ich.
Und dann gibt es noch Franzosen und Schweizer, die bauen glaube ich einen Großteil ihrer Seilbahnen heutzutage in Städten und nicht mehr in den Alpen oder im Kaukasus oder sonst wo.
Also das ist tatsächlich entdeckt worden.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wer der erste war, ich glaube vor Medellin war noch Carakas dran.
In Medellin funktioniert es natürlich auch deswegen sehr gut, weil es topografisch eine herausfordernde Stadt ist.
Also es hat große Höhenunterschiede, die nicht einfach überwunden werden können.
Und es hat aber natürlich auch Sicherheitsaspekte.
Also eine Seilbahn geht halt über Gebiete drüber hinweg, die man vielleicht mit Auto und zu Fuß und Fahrrad nicht unbedingt durchqueren möchte.
Was ja auch wiederum wichtig ist, der breiten Bevölkerung Zugänglichkeiten, zum Beispiel auch zu Stadtzentren, wo oftmals auch die wirtschaftliche Aktivität geballt ist, zu ermöglichen.
Also in Medellin sind teilweise Arbeitswege gekürzt worden von über 30-40 Minuten.
Und plötzlich wird es machbar für Menschen.
Gleichzeitig ist dann auch die Frage, wie viel kosten die eigentlich und können die Leute, die in den informellen Settlements dort wohnen, sich das eigentlich leisten?
Also das sind spannende Fragen.
Mal gucken, wann wir denn Seilbahnen auch noch in deutschen Zentren finden.
Hier und da gibt es das ja schon.
Wir müssen ja gar nicht so weit, da ist ja die IGA mit eine angeschlossen worden, die, wenn mich nicht alles täuscht, auch weiter betrieben werden soll.
Es gibt glaube ich einen Vertrag mit dem Hersteller auch über 5-10 Jahre mindestens, das mal zu testen.
Gut das spannt natürlich so eine noch relativ überschaubare Parklandschaft mit zwei Stationen, das ist noch nicht so.
Nein, das ist verkehrsstrategisch vielleicht …
Berlin hat auch nicht unbedingt so das Höhenprofil, was jetzt unbedingt nach Seilbahnbetrieb schreit.
Und es hat natürlich auch wirklich immer die Probleme, auch rechtliche Probleme, Überflugprobleme.
Also was ist aus Brixen in Südtirol, da wird das gerade geplant, um ein Dorf oberhalb von Brixen anzuschließen.
Wo sich ganz tüchtig darum gestritten wird, wie viel Überflugrechte eigentlich gegeben werden müssen und was akzeptabel ist oder nicht.
Und insofern ist das glaube ich bei uns nur bedingt ein Verkehrsmittel.
Und obendrein muss man sich fragen, baggert das eigentlich auch die Kapazitäten weg, die wir wirklich brauchen?
Um vielleicht mal so langsam zum Ende zu kommen, ich würde jetzt ganz gern nochmal so ein bisschen in den unbekannten Raum reintragen, was wir einerseits vielleicht noch nicht touchiert haben, aber was sozusagen jetzt auch so spannende Entwicklungen betrifft in deiner Forschung.
Wir haben jetzt über Digitalisierung am Rande ein wenig gesprochen, tatsächlich steht es ja auch so im Mittelpunkt der Forschungsarbeit.
Worauf müssen wir uns einstellen oder was sind sagen wir mal auch so optimistische Sichtweisen auf die urbane Entwicklung?
Was kann nochmal richtig Spaß machen, was sind die größten Herausforderungen?
Spaß bringen wird hoffentlich, dass die Stadt insgesamt lebenswerter gestaltet werden kann.
Sprich, wir haben vorhin schon von den Parkplätzen geredet, dass wir Raum, der momentan für  Nutzung vorgehalten wird, die mit urbaner Qualität nur bedingt was zu tun habe, vielleicht anders strukturieren können, anders organisieren können.
Ich denke nur, da gibt es eine ganze Menge Technologien, die uns ermöglichen, Stadt anders zu benutzen.
Und vielleicht Räume freizuschaufeln, wo wir dann andere Dinge machen können.
Zum Beispiel?
Also da gibt es schon eine ganze Menge Feldversuche auch, die einfach mal, ich glaube in London hat da irgendwer mal mit angefangen, die haben eine kleine Straße komplett freigeräumt und Rasen ausgerollt.
Es war ein Feldversuch nur für ein Wochenende glaube ich, aber die haben dann natürlich geschaut, was tut sich denn stattdessen dann da?
Welche Qualitäten, welche Gemeinschaften können da entstehen.
Nachbarschaften in Großstädten in der Regel sind … Also könnte ich mir vorstellen, dass der gesellschaftliche Zusammenhalt höher sein könnte hier und da.
Können wir Räume gestalten in diesen Flächen, die noch momentan zugeparkt sind, wo Menschen sich anders begegnen können.
Ist es vielleicht sogar so, dass wenn heute Morgen im Spiegel die nächste Vorhersage, was die künstliche Intelligenz oder Digitalisierung an Arbeitsplätzen ersetzt und dann kommt auch immer automatisch hinterher, brauchen wir eigentlich ein bedingungsloses Grundeinkommen?
Wenn wir das mal durchdenken, bedeutet das, dass die Leute mehr zu Hause sind vielleicht und auch flexibler vielleicht arbeiten können von zu Hause.
Was bedeutet das für so ein Stadtquartier, wenn die Leute mehr da sind?
Ich hoffe nicht, dass sie mehr auf ihrem Sofa sitzen, sondern dass es auch andere Qualitäten der Begegnung geben kann, die vielleicht dann auch dazu führen, dass ein Quartier, eine Quartiersgesellschaft anders miteinander fungiert und anders zusammenkommt und anders sich integriert.
Diese Debatte am bedingungslosen Grundeinkommen verschärft sich meiner Auffassung nach auch immer so ein bisschen an dieser Schnittkante, die auch bisschen so ideologisch ist.
So dieses, wie verstehen wir eigentlich unser Zusammenleben?
Ist das sozusagen alles arbeitsorientiert?
Ist Arbeit ein Wert an sich oder ist Arbeit eigentlich etwas, was gar nicht gut ist, und wir wären doch alle viel besser dran, wenn wir so was gar nicht machen müssen.
Das ist natürlich auch so ein ideologischer Blick mit, kann ja nicht sein, gerade in Deutschland wo Arbeit auch so ein unglaublich aufgeladenes Element ist.
Wo da Ehre und Wertschätzung und Aufstieg und Karriere und all diese ganzen Dinge, die dann ja auch selber sozusagen … wo einem selbst auch ein Wert zugeschrieben wird, wenn man eine bestimmte Arbeit leistet oder eine Arbeit hat auch nur.
Versus ein, naja muss denn unbedingt jeder?
Es wird ja sowieso nicht jeder arbeiten.
Und selbst wenn wir mal so Situationen jetzt herstellen können, wo die allermeiste arbeiten, wo manche schon anfangen von Vollbeschäftigung zu reden.
Auch wenn das glaube ich eine Chimäre ist.
Dann ist viel dieser Arbeit, die dann unter Umständen geleistet wird, auch gar nicht wertvoll im eigentlichen Sinne.
Und insbesondere nicht wertvoll für die Leute auch selbst.
In dem Moment, wo man das aufbricht, könnte sich natürlich auch für die Stadt wieder eine interessante neue Option ergebne, weil ja einfach viel mehr Leute Zeit und dann vielleicht auch Lust haben, sich lokal zu engagieren, kommunal zu engagieren.
Für eine Nachbarschaft etwas zu organisieren, wo sonst einfach überhaupt niemand da wäre
Völlig richtig.
Das ist, vielleicht kann ich darauf zurückkommen, auf unser Designstudio, wo wir uns mit Neuhohenschönhausen beschäftigen momentan, eine Schlafstadt im Grunde genommen, die tatsächlich aber eine ganze Menge Freiraum drumherum hat, der momentan relativ ungeniert ist und man da zumindest werktags am Tag gar nicht viele Leute findet.
Wir fragen uns momentan, wie kann unter den Voraussetzungen, die du gerade skizziert hast, so ein Raum anders funktionieren?
Was braucht er an anderen Räumen?
Wie kann man Leute anhalten zusammenzukommen.
Anders miteinander auch weiter zu arbeiten?
Wie kann man sich weiter qualifizieren?
Es ist ja nicht so, dass wir dann nicht mehr arbeiten werden, sondern wir können vielleicht uns Arbeitsformen widmen, die vorher anders bewertet waren.
Oder du sprachst von dem sozialen Zusammenhalt.
Also bei allen Studien, die man sich anguckt, ist ja gerade der soziale Aspekt der am schwersten zu ersetzen ist, Gott sei dank.
Wie kann das neue fast Betriebssysteme von Nachbarschaften generieren?
Ein Projekt von unseren Studenten beschäftigt sich genau damit, wie können wir Arbeitsgemeinschaft, also so ein System von Arbeitsgemeinschaften erfinden, wo die Leute ihre Zeit einbringen und trotzdem die Gesamtheit des Stadtviertels neu zusammenbringen können.
Aber auch Leistungen geleistet werden, die einfach gemacht werden müssen.
Die wiederum aber auch vielleicht bedenken, dass man weniger Miete bezahlen muss.
Da tut sich ganz viel denke ich mal.
Und die Digitalisierung hat ganz viele problematische Dinge, die man da mitdenken muss, die wir schon angesprochen haben.
Aber sie kann uns glaube ich auch ganz viel Freiraum schaffen, wenn wir sie denn richtig einsetzen.
Denn einfach zu verstehen, was wo wann notwendig ist, um das zu organisieren, dass es auch funktioniert, denn irgendwie Frustrationslevel gehen ganz schnell hoch.
Wir sprachen vorhin bei der Mobilität davon, wenn das nächste Bikesharing irgendwie drei Minuten entfernt ist, dann sagen wir, okay gehen hin.
Aber wenn das Ding dann dort nicht steht, dann ist man ganz schnell dabei zu sagen, oh Gott beim nächsten Mal steige ich gleich ins Auto ein.
Und ich glaube, da können wir ganz viel durch die Digitalisierung auch gewinnen.
Und müssen aufpassen, welche Freiheitsgrade wir uns da neu aneignen können.
Gleichzeitig müssen wir aufpassen, wer diese Freiheit bestimmt, diese Systeme, die dahinter sind.
Schönes Schlusswort würde ich sagen.
Ja Jochen Rabe vielen Dank.
Ich danke auch.
Es hat mir großen Spaß gemacht.
Ja mir auch.
Und ja ich hoffe, es hat auch allen Spaß gemacht, hier wieder zuzuhören bei Forschergeist.
Ich sage, tschüss und bis bald.